laurence bonne journaliste
d'investigation auteur du livre de la
honte les réseaux pédophiles aux
éditions cherche midi bonsoy ans
laurence boehner alors ça fait faire
évidemment fait froid dans le dos on la
découvre aujourd'hui son ampleur est
encore inconnue oui bah en fait de toute
façon les dés dans ce genre d'affaires
les l'ampleur est toujours inconnue j'ai
même quand enfin on remet ministre temps
c'est à dire que de toute manière on est
toujours extrêmement de sa de l'ampleur
du de l'ampleur du réseau et du
phénomène et là-haut très récemment en
allemagne aussi il ya donc on a parlé de
ya onze personnes qui sont fait arrêter
en a trois victimes
il est raisonnable de penser qu'il ya
des centaines de victimes et énormément
de monde
énormément de prédateurs est ce qu'on
peut parler clairement un madame de
scandales étouffés aujourd'hui où cette
lecture ne seraient pas bonnes alors
étouffé je ne sais pas disons qu'on peut
parler au minimum d'un manque d'intérêt
qui fait que les prédateurs sont très
recherchés en fait le le le le phénomène
est beaucoup minimiser et on met pas du
tout les moyens qu'il faudrait par
rapport à l'ampleur du phénomène c'est
quelque chose faite en fait c'est
quelque chose que les visiblement les
politiques publiques ne considère pas du
tout comme prioritaires ça veut dire
pardonnez-moi première qu'on comprenne
ça veut dire vous parler d'aujourd'hui
parce que c'est c'est une expérience
entre guillemets si on peut appeler ça
comme ça qui date de plusieurs années on
sait que la culture était peut-être si
différente par rapport justement à la
pédophilie qui semblait alors justement
je parle sous votre contrôle et et puis
je souhaiterais votre nom votre analyse
en ce domaine mais qui était peut-être
presque voilà toléré il fut un temps
l'impression en allemagne est en tout
cas mais elle sait pas si c'est pas vrai
en fait on dit que je dire on parle de
l'allemagne
on parle de la france si on regarde les
législations elle était plutôt plus dur
contre un an
alors effectivement il ya il y avait ce
côté post soixante huitard donc il ya eu
tout un mouvement philosophique si vous
voulez qui effectivement où il y avait
une certaine tolérance vis-à-vis des
dérives pédocriminels mais si on regarde
les législations et si on regarde les
peines encourues et les peines
prononcées en fait c'était plutôt plus
dur c'est c'est c'est pas vrai que c'est
pas vrai que c'était plutôt les rangs
avant en tout cas pas dans les textes il
semblerait que justement cette
expérience du professeur de psychologie
hellmuth ken clair voilà a été tolérée
validé par les autorités béninoises 1 on
rappelle que ce professeur de
psychologie estimé qu'il est pédophile
peut être aller mieux s'occuper des
enfants qu'est ce que ça vous inspire
mais parce qu'effectivement cette
théorisation là c'est une théorie c'est
une théorisation qui existe depuis très
longtemps qui a encore cours aujourd'hui
je lisais pas plus tard que cet
après-midi un un article scientifique
aux psychologies qu enfin sais pas quoi
entre guillemets qui s'appelait la
panique pédophiles et qui est pas très
vieille
enfin c'est de l'article et l'article à
quelques années mais il n'est pas très
vieux et en fait il y à il ya sept ya
cette théorisation vous savez dans le il
ya certaines yahia encore que même
certaines personnes par exemple pour
dire que par les dénoncer les crimes
pédocriminels c'est pas bon pour les
enfants
voilà il ya il ya une théorisation qui
dit que en fait c'est une espèce de
réflexe réactionnaires qui fait qu'on
refuse la pédocriminalité aujourd'hui
c'est à dire quand on gomme complètement
les dégâts incroyables que ça fait sur
les sur les gosses et que et on fait des
analogies par exemple avec
l'homosexualité handed en avant
l'homosexualité est est criminalisé
maintenant elle ne l'est plus et dans
quelques années
dans 10 ans ou 20 ans enfin arrivera le
jour où on regardera cet assaut
pédocriminels comme quelque chose de
parfaitement réactionnaire d'intention
quoi aujourd'hui est ce que on a un
suivi de ces victimes puisqu'on peut les
appeler tout de même le jeu j'imagine
des victimes clairement qu'elles sont
voilà leur compensation notamment et
surtout on parlait ddm dégâts quels sont
leur état psychologique aujourd'hui
alors là vous parlez d d d
si vous parlez des victimes du vivant du
passé oui tout à fait de cette affaire
alors commençons comment dans cette
affaire précisément comment les victimes
ont été indemnisées je ne sais pas ce
que je sais c'est que de toute façon
c'est très rare en fait il ya une quand
il ya un procès en général les
indemnisations sont très faibles ça
c'est vrai ya à peu près partout
à part peut-être défaut aux états unis
encore par rapport au préjudice subi
en général elles doivent se débrouiller
tout seuls avec leurs traumatismes et et
ça c'est encore vrai aujourd'hui alors
il ya eu une exception avec l'allemagne
parce qu'on ya eu cet énorme scandale
qu'on a découverte justement aussi au
fil des décennies des milliers de
victimes de l'église où donc gia eut un
fonds qui a été mis en place mais
d'ailleurs c'est un fonds qui étaient
mis en place par l'église mais en
général et elles sont extrêmement
laissés-pour-compte à les victimes de
paix de criminels quand elles ont de la
chance
elles obtiennent justice et déjà ils
peuvent s'estimer chanceuse parce
qu'elle n'a pas beaucoup c'est de le
pourcentage est un film et tient après
pour leur reconstruction va ma foi se
débrouille
merci alors les moyens de s'offrir à une
thérapie tant mieux sinon tant pis pour
elle merci à vous laurence abonnés
d'avoir été avec nous on les
investigations auteur du livre de la
honte les réseaux pédophiles aux
éditions cherche midi